this year we had a record 2 755
billionaires
on the list and to see at least 40 of
those come from
companies that had direct ties in
fighting cove it was really interesting
proportionately it's not that big but
it's such a large number
of newcomers not just from healthcare
but specifically from efforts to fight
coveted products to fight covet
the soaring stock market really helped a
lot of healthcare companies in
particular
of course you have the big names such as
moderna and by on tech with pfizer
along with the coven vaccines those
companies obviously have been the ones
that have been most
well known to people around the world
because of their work with vaccines
and they were the ones who also minted
several billionaires
beyond that a lot of other companies in
the healthcare space that are probably
traded have done very well
you have makers of ppe makers of
medical equipment and medical devices
you have companies that
work with pharmaceutical companies that
make vaccines to do
clinical trials so it really sort of
runs the gamut of all the different
products that healthcare companies have
been putting out there
the richest newcomer we had to the list
this year from a company that was
involved in fighting covet
was lee jianchuan of winter medical
based in hong kong
they made billions of masks and millions
of protective overalls and gallons of
health carbohydrates fighting the virus
starting out in china and then of course
around the world as well the second
richest and probably
the best known to have emerged over the
past year is stefan bonsell who's the
ceo of moderna and then the third
and fourth richest are you fungi of
indico medical in china
which makes again gloves masks isolation
gowns and other ppe
and then we have uresha him of biontech
in germany
he was the ceo and co-founder of that
company along with his wife who's also
the cmo of the company and they they
partnered with pfizer to make the first
vaccine approved by regulators
some other interesting people from this
list are tim springer who is a
harvard professor and a scientist and
then in 2010 he became a founding
investor of moderna
hasn't sold a single share and he's
become a billionaire off of that
investment
and then another person with a similar
sort of background to joining the list
as tim springer is robert langer
who is a scientist and professor at mit
who's been dubbed the edison of medicine
for his inventions
and development in the space he also was
the founder of moderna
and received shares for that has never
sold a single share and is also a
millionaire thanks as an investment
inverter
you